it is a distinct pleasure to speak for
all of us in welcoming to Yale to New
Haven and to the Betty Macmillan Center
for International and area studies his
excellency POV mole the ambassador of
france to the united states ambassador
vemo a distinguished graduate of both
the st to deter politique and the ecole
nationale d'administration has been a
member of the French Foreign Service
since 1977 his postings have taken him
to London as first secretary to the
press and information office at the cato
say to the Institute for east-west
security in New York and to the European
Union in Brussels ambassador vemo has
served as deputy director-general of
cultural scientific and technical
relations and also as director of
European cooperation from 1999 to 2002
mr. vimal was ambassador and permanent
representative of france to the european
union following that assignment he spent
five years as the electoral to kabini to
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs last
August he was appointed by President
Sarkozy as ambassador to the United
States where he replaced Jean dahveed
Levite who many of us here remember from
the analysis he shared with us shortly
after the first Iraqi elections of the
then-new turn in franco-american
relations this afternoon as Nicolas
Sarkozy prepares to assume the
presidency of the European Union
ambassador vemo will speak to us on the
subject France Europe and the United
States what prospects for transatlantic
relations ambassador
thank you very much for your kind words
and I apologize for the alarm sounding
but in fact it has been following me
since i arrived in Yale I suppose
somebody is trying to prevent me from
speaking and maybe maybe he's right let
me tell you how how pleased and honored
I am to be with all of you this this
afternoon to give you some brief remarks
about France Europe and the United
States and what the prospects can we
inspect in in that relationship but also
if you wish to answer your your
questions afterwards if we have a some
time and I hope we will have some so I
won't be too long in what I think should
be considered as introductory remarks so
to allow you to to give your thoughts or
to ask questions if you want afterwards
I will briefly go through three or four
observations because I think this is
maybe the better way to pinpoint a few
observations so that it allows you to
know exactly where we are at the moment
in fact and very kindly so the former
speaker talked about Jean that he'd
lived it was a close friend of mine and
in fact was somewhat instrumental in my
coming here after after he went back to
Paris Jonathan if it went through a
difficult time because the relations
between our two countries at that time
were going through a difficult period
because of our differences of you on the
Iraq intervention I happen to be a very
happy ambassador him I come here at a
time when in doubt ibly the relationship
and the friendship between our two
countries has been improving
tremendously in the last 12 months and I
think this is due to one major factor we
all know it is the election of president
Korra Sarkozy president nicolas sarkozy
stated as soon as he was elected but he
had even stated that previously during
his campaign that he wanted to change
the mood
the relationship between our two
countries and that he definitely want to
go back to the true constructive and
positive partnership that we had between
our two countries and in fact what is
important is that he not only said that
during the campaign first of all and
that did not prevent him from being
elected which tells you a lot about I
would say the friendship the true
friendship between our two countries
because a lot of political analysts went
on saying as he was stating that during
his campaign that that was the best
recipe for disaster and electoral defeat
and in fact Nicolas Sarkozy stood to his
point keep kept on with his course and
managed to get elected by a clear-cut
majority and a clear-cut turn over turn
out sorry of french voters as we had
more than 75 percent of the french voter
who went to vote and cast their ballots
in the two rounds of our presidential
election last year so it was important
that it tells a lot about the the
friendship about our two countries but
what was more important is that nicolas
sarkozy stated that position as soon as
he was elected in fact on the night of
his election among the few priorities he
set up immediately on that night was the
need to repair the relationship between
france and the united states and to
launch a new momentum in that
relationship and also he talked about
europe and the need for france to be
back in the main street of the europe
european construction and i'll come back
to that in a in a few seconds but
therefore he Nicolas Sarkozy stated very
clearly that he wanted to push the
relationship between our two countries
ahead and in fact what is interesting is
that he did that immediately with a few
initiatives he took very briefly and to
show really what he meant by revamping
or giving a new momentum to the year
relation and the partnership between
between our two countries first of all
Afghanistan on this issue very briefly
and after
month Nicolas Sarkozy said publicly that
he thought it was necessary to increase
the French military contribution to
Afghanistan because we were there for a
long time we needed we know that this is
a long-term issue that we have to face a
terrible challenge to all the members of
the NATO coalition and it was in no way
should we try to leave Afghanistan
because it would be a test of the
success of the failure of NATO so
therefore we had to be there France was
ready to take up its responsibilities
there and to send more troops but at the
same time he said also that we should be
very careful in trying to redefine the
kind of global strategy we have in
Afghanistan and that in Afghanistan it
was not only a question of pouring more
soldiers into that country but it is
also and maybe for most defining the
kind of relationship we want to have
with President Karzai and the leadership
there how to work with them and the
different tribal areas and different
tribal leaders in Afghanistan what kind
of public assistance were managed to
bring to the Afghan economy into the
Afghan social life what kind of
relationship also we try to define with
Pakistan the neighboring country there
which is playing also a major part in
the Afghan crisis so it was at the same
time sending troops and also asking and
pleading with our European partners and
our NATO partners for a new definition
of the kind of strategy we should have
in Afghanistan the second issue on which
nicolas sarkozy has moved very quickly
was Nate oh and the idea that at the
same time as we intend to enhance our
European defense and to try to improve
and increase our European capacities in
the defense field we were ready also to
look here at the implication of such a
European defence on NATO and on the
future of NATO
and therefore this was a new change also
in our policy manager you have to be
aware that contrary to what is quite
often said France has been back in NATO
already for many years this is not
really a secret and contrary to what
quite often is written about the
relation between France and NATO in fact
we are back again in all the ministerial
meetings our forces are participating in
many of the external military operations
of NATO just think about Kosovo Bosnia
Afghanistan I was talking a few minutes
ago and furthermore we are now more or
less participating in all the working
groups except for two of them so when
we're talking about going back into NATO
one has to understand that in fact we're
already there for most part of it and
what is left really is the question of
getting some of our officer back into
the year our key and the military
organization the integrated military
organization that is established in
Brussels and in which for the time being
we don't have a lot of officers being
there so this was also a major move that
nicolasa cody has announced and we are
ready to go on and to go into that
direction but we want first of all
during the last semester I will come
back to that very briefly we want first
of all to discuss the whole question of
European defence with our partners in
the European Union and it's it's only
after we have made up our mind about the
way to enhance that European defence
that we will be ready to look at the
implications for NATO and the third
example of what nicolas sarkozy has done
as soon as you arrived is for instance
iran with regard to Iran and the nuclear
issues surrounding that country nicolas
sarkozy has taken a very firm position
we had already a strong position before
he was elected but he has to a large
degree enhanced it and confirmed it and
put as much pressure as possible on the
tehran regime france has been in the
leading seat in order to
move the sanctions the economic and
financial sanctions against Iran we were
part of the third resolution that was
recently adopted in them in the in the
year Security Council in in the United
Nations and France there has played a
major role in trying to get an agreement
between all the different parties the 15
members of the Security Council at the
same time and there you will see also
this traditional balance that France
tries to get whenever it looks at some
of those complicated international
issues at the same time we have stated
that as we had a strong and major
political part in trying to increase the
pressure of sanctions against Iran at
the same time we want it to be known and
clearly known in Tehran that there was
on the other side also interesting
proposals to end that an easiness and
that tension that we have with Iran this
is the famous stick and carrot approach
we have a stick on one side but we also
have a carrot and we tend sometimes to
forget that the carrot is there and even
the Iranian public opinion it's
sometimes unaware of the existence of
that carrot and we think it is very
important to remind them about that so
we have also dare played a major part in
trying to improve the package of
proposals we have put forward towards
the Iranians and recently we have
managed to get an agreement among the
six major countries that are dealing
with this issue and we are our intention
is to try to push forward that idea and
those proposals towards the Iranian
public opinion so that they understand
that if they will be would be ready to
suspend their present nuclear enrichment
process which is what the international
community has been asking now for more
than two years if Tehran accepts to
suspend for the time being its
enrichment process then there is a lot
of possible interesting initiatives to
take with them with regard to civilian
nuclear energy with regard to new
technologies being offered to the
Iranians with
possibility of a strategic dialogue with
Iran and the other countries in the area
in other words to allow around to play
its part in the region and to have a
real political influence but a real
political positive influence and not the
kind of influence they're trying to have
at the moment which is a rather negative
one so those are some of the initiatives
nicolas sarkozy has set forth as soon as
you arrived and we were a clear
testimony to the way he wanted to
improve the relationship between our two
countries and i must say that since he
arrived one year ago in power in france
the atmosphere of the relationship
between our two countries have endowed
ablame proved and even if we may have
differences here and there there is one
clear conclusion that we can set and we
can say now is that now that our
European partners understand better that
France is ready to have an improved
relationship with the United States now
every time France may come with a new
idea inside the European Union and you
know that France relishes selling new
ideas to its partner they won't think
immediately that it is another trick by
the French to try to get rid of the
Americans and I think this is something
rather interesting in order to improve
and to improve the kind of relations
were going to have with our European
partners for and this is I think the
second observation I wanted to take
Europe is I would say the second
international priority that our
president has set up very clearly when
he was elected just to remind you where
we were on the night of his election in
in may 2007 in fact europe was blocked
for the last two years since may 2005
because of two referendum that took
place in France and in the Netherlands
to referendum during which the voters
from France and from netherlands had
refused to adopt
the draft constitutional treaty that had
been prepared for the last three or four
years by the European Convention and in
fact with this negative vote nothing
really happened in Europe in the last
two years everybody was waiting for
France to come out with a new
initiatives a new idea in order to get
out of the stalemate where we were and
in fact it was obvious that nothing
would happen until a new president was
elected we had to wait for that
presidential election what has been very
interesting is that Nicolas Sarkozy as
soon as he was elected gave two signals
and to clear messages to the his
European counterparts that allowed for
all of us to get out of the situation
where we were and to get quickly the
adoption of this treaty if even if we
have changed the form the two ideas were
very simple the first one was to say
that France wanted to become once again
a clear constructive partner in the
European Union that we will play our
role in the best way possible and the
second one which may look a little bit
technical but which was very important
to our partners was to say that if we
agreed on a new treaty France would
ratify this treaty through the
Parliament and not anymore through a
referendum and that of course was the
clear signal to our partners that we
were serious about that treaty because
to get back into a new negotiation on
that treaty without being sure that
France this time would ratify the treaty
was for many of our partners a clear
political obstacle and this obstacle
could not be a surpassed if we didn't
give a clear signal that we would find
the right way to proceed so as to
guarantee that France this time was
serious and if we got an agreement on
that new draft treaty France would
ratify it without any problem so once
those two signals were sent to our
partners we were able to go ahead rather
quickly we got a new a new treaty before
the end of the year and got it signed in
December at the European Council in
December in discipline and since then
since the beginning of 2000 or eight
this year every of the 27 countries is
in the present process
of ratifying this treaty we all hope
that it will be done by the end of the
year we have only i would say one
uncertainty it could be island ireland
will have to ratify the treaty through
referendum and a real problem in ireland
is that nobody is really interested at
the moment in that referendum you seem
to have more than fifty percent of the
population of the voters who don't
intend to go to the polls and therefore
the result could be really uncertain and
and we have to be careful about that but
apart from ireland all the other
countries are going a hand more than
half i think today of the member states
have ratified and we are now facing a
new situation if we managed by the end
of the year to get a total ratification
by all the member states my third
observation about europe will be that
precisely where are we heading for now
with europe as we go ahead and as france
as it was reminded a few seconds ago is
going to chair the european union from
the first of july right up to the end of
the year being the president of the
european union is in fact a very modest
charger i mean in the sense that you
have to play this charge with great
modesty and not try to come out with
great initiatives but look really at
what are the challenges that are there
on the table and try in your own modest
way to push as far as possible these
solutions that we're trying to find
among the 27 countries and try to give
to the presidency that will follow you
the czech republic in on this occasion
to try to give to the czech republic
burden of work to do that will be as
much alleviated and as much as light as
possible when they take over the
presidency if you do that you are a good
presidency if you give to your to the
future president see more problems than
you had when you arrived something has
gone wrong now what are the kind of
challenges we are facing there are many
but let me just
four main challenges so that you
understand the first one has to do with
the demography of Europe we are at the
moment the 27 countries something around
four hundred ninety million population
if we go along with the present birth
rate in 25 30 years from now we will be
less than that will be something like
470 million which means that we will
have a drop of something like 20 million
people in our European Union and this is
due to the fact as I was mentioning a
few seconds ago due to the fact that in
most of those countries with the
exception of France mind you the
birthrate doesn't allow the population
to be replaced 1121 France is the only
country which is so far managing to do
that and therefore that brings about the
whole question of immigration of legal
legal immigration naughty League of the
legal immigration as we will need to
find people to get some of the jobs that
we will have as we go along and as our
economy will will grow up and if we go
along for legal immigration that means
that all the 27 of us of our countries
need to have a common set of rules how
we will allow some of these people to
come in what kind of coming rules will
we have for the people who will come and
apply for for a right of entry into one
of the European countries what do we do
for people who apply for political
asylum also do we manage to set up the
common set of rules there also France
has a clear idea about what we should
try to do mostly support the legal
immigration based on people coming to
find a job and not only to allow
immigration of people who want to gather
with their family that is already there
you know at the present moment in France
we opened those mostly to family or we
get a gathering family reunion ninety
percent of our immigrants legal
immigrants come for that purpose and
only ten percent come for jobs and we
would like to change that balance to get
something like fifty percent
fifty-fifty half coming for jobs have
coming for family reunions and we would
like to see if our partners share this
idea and try to get a common agreement
on that we also have to ask for those
illegal legal immigrants who will come
ask them to have some notions about
french language and about how our french
society is working so they don't get a
so that their integration i would say in
the french society will be as easy as
possible so this is the cookies are the
kinds of ideas we want to share with our
partners to see if we can all agree
that's for the first challenge the
demographic one the second one has to do
a lot with innovation and competition at
the moment if you look at the European
figures at the figures inside the
European Union our research represents
something like one point eight percent
of average of the GDP of our countries
where we wanted to go as far as three
percent when we launched an economic
strategy in Lisbon at the beginning of
this 20th 21st century when we wanted to
make the Europeans as competitive as
possible in the global economy so we
have to bridge that gap and there is a
lot of work that we must do in order to
improve our research sector and our
innovation and the part we can play in
new technology this brings about a lot
of problems and I want to go into too
many of them because we don't have too
much time here but let me just remind
you that for instance in France at the
moment the financing of the research
sector is mostly done on the shoulders
of the government two-thirds of the
financing of the research financing has
to go through public money and of course
we need to promote more private
financing through enterprises or
endowments etc in order to get a better
balance and we are very far from there
from that at the moment and most of the
European country are more or less in the
same situation as we are so we have to
work much more on that as we go
the third son challenge and therefore
that will also be a main priority on the
French presidency is the climate change
the questions about climate change and
energy we happen to be lucky in Europe
because by different decisions that have
been taken so far the impact of
greenhouse gas emissions it's much lower
than for instance in your country with a
difference from 1 2 3 or 12 for even in
some places of course for a country like
France this is due to a large part to
the proportion of nuclear energy that we
have you know that eighty percent nearly
eighty percent between 75 and eighty
percent of our electricity is from
nuclear origin and therefore that helps
us a lot to stick to the commitments
that were accepted by the european union
with regard to the Kyoto Protocol as we
have signed and accepted to go along but
we want to go further than that and this
is where discussion will have to go on
between Europeans as we have decided
between the 27 of us that we would also
go for new sources renewable resources
and that that that share of renewable
resources would be in 2020 more than
twenty percent of the total amount of
energy resources so we have to work on
that we have to take national
commitments now that we have set up that
European commitment that European go and
this also will be one of the major
priorities that we will have to face
during our presidency and the fourth and
last challenge we are facing is the one
I mentioned briefly about when I talked
about European defence it is i would say
the world challenge in other words what
contribution can europe bring today to
world affairs as we go on wanting to
have a stronger integration among
European partners we really need to see
what kind of role what part can you
reply in the world tomorrow and mind you
this is not easy I'm
about defense i'm talking about foreign
policy it's not easy because we're 27
today and to try to get a common
position on any kind of international
issue we're facing today when you are 27
this becomes a major challenge in itself
for those of us who have been working in
brussels for many years never forget
that for some of us who has started to
work on those as you were at the end of
the 70s we were at that time only nine
around the table then Greece came in
then Spain and Portugal we for many
years were then 12 around the table then
we became 15 and now we're 27 and that
brings about practical problems that you
may think are not too important but in
fact our very important not everyday
working life that means a lot of
interpreters that have to be around the
table and some of them cannot enter
cannot translate directly from Estonian
to to French they have to go through
German no British for instance which
means that you have a long time in terms
of trajectory translation which means
that when you're trying a joke in order
to to hearten the the meetings people
don't understand your joke until five
five minutes later so the whole
atmosphere is it's not exactly the one
you you're wishing and furthermore that
if only you allow the different
ministers to speak around the table the
27 of them you know ministers they like
to speak five or 10 minutes 10 minutes
that's it's nearly three or four hours
of other tool the tablet as we say in
France which means that when you have
ended a first round of the table with
those 27 ministers the meeting is more
or less over and everybody wants to get
back to his capital that means that
those are big dose meetings are becoming
very formal nothing really interesting
is really happening there and more and
more we have to think of better ways to
give more flexibility to that European
Union and to those European meetings and
if we really want to have strong foreign
see able to play its part with Europe
playing its part in the Middle East
peace process with regard to Iraq with
regard to Kosovo with regard to Burma
that means that more and more we will
have to think about setting up new rules
flexible rules in order to allow some of
those countries some of those European
countries which are the most interested
in those issue to take the lead and to
try to work together with the other
countries allowing this small group of
countries to take the lead and go ahead
enjoy them later on if they wish so but
to alleviate the process so that we are
managed to have something that is
efficient constructive and positive my
last remark which will be with regard to
the United Nation to the United States
and of course the transatlantic
relations because at the same time as
France is going to have the presidency
in the next six months facing those four
challenges I spoke to you about you're
gonna experience here a change of
administration a new administration is
going to be whoever is elected president
it will be a new administration and
Europe of course will have to work with
that new administration and what is very
interesting is that the time when France
will represent Europe you find out that
many of the challenges were facing off
in Europe are also some of the major fat
challenges we partners of the
transatlantic relationship on each side
of the Atlantic are gonna face exactly
the same and therefore there is no doubt
that we need to work together on many of
those issues because what is interesting
in what I would like to stress for one
second is that as we go along in the
global world that we're facing today and
we discover little by little older
consequences for our economy for the
question related to environment we may
not have understood well enough and
precisely enough what would be also the
consequences of the global world for
diplomatic relations and for all our
international affairs in other words as
we go along and
the world is becoming more and more
complicated and complex it is becoming
more and more difficult for one country
to be to just think that they're going
to find a solution for everybody it is
becoming more and more complicated to
think that each of those issues were
facing has only one dimension whether it
be military or political quite often
they're both and there are many others
issue related also to that and many
other dimension the religious one the
cultural one the social one and we're
finding that now we're facing issues
think about Afghanistan but think also
about Iraq think about the peace process
as it is going on which is becoming more
and more complicated because all the
issues related that are appearing in the
Middle East are now more and more
connected you one can find out that as
we go ahead what is happening with the
Hamas in the Palestinian territories has
something to do also with Syria with the
Hezbollah in Lebanon with Iraq with Iran
of course which is there very much over
all those issues and as we go along we
discovered and now all those issues a
normal complex and that we have all of
us to work together so first of all we
certainly have to work between the
United States and Europe let me just
name some of those issues that we were
going to face together climate change of
course of which I was talking a few
minutes ago but think of so about the
whole question of non-proliferation
nuclear non-proliferation as we go ahead
and we try to solve the Iran issue you
can be assured that we will think more
and more about how to adapt the
non-proliferation rules that exist at
the moment the NPT treaty that is there
at the moment that we have to modernize
and find new ways of controlling nuclear
f activities in all these in all these
come in all the different countries so
non-proliferation will be certainly a
major issue but think also about the
turmoil and the disorder at the moment
of the crisis in the financial
good as we find out that we will have to
find some way of bringing more order
into those markets maybe some regulation
it will certainly be to the year of the
responsibility of many of our countries
to try at least to exchange use exchange
our expertise exchange our experience to
see how we go ahead and therefore there
is no doubt that as we go along we will
have to work together on this but it's
not only about those issues I think it
is also about the method and this is the
last observation I would like to give to
you as we go along we are discovering
that nowadays we have to bring more
countries inside the I would say the
mainstream of diplomatic action let me
give you another example still related
to Iran as we go along and we try to
push our idea and to convince the
Iranians that they should suspend their
present enrichment process we have
discovered that countries like Brazil
like South Africa like Mexico like
Indonesia or others could be very
helpful in getting the message through
to Iran and trying to put some friendly
pressure on the Iranians and therefore
those countries really need to be on
board and to be able to discuss with the
six major countries that are at the
moment trying to find a way through to
the negotiation with Iran and this can
be true also about many other issues and
this is why Frances of the opinion that
as we go along we need to have new
international institution where all
those countries will be represented we
can't go on with the Security Council in
New York which has only five permanent
members and which leave outside of this
group of the five permanent
representative country like and just
think about it for a second Japan
Germany Brazil South Africa and many
others and the same thing is true about
the g8 meeting we have meetings every
year right
at the level of the heads of state and
government who are there to discuss
about the present economic situation and
there in those meetings you don't have
China you don't have India you don't
have Brazil or you don't have South
Africa and it seems to us at least to
France and I think we are not alone in
saying that that this cannot go on if we
want to keep legitimacy if we want to
keep some sort of international
Authority even if we just only keep
credibility we need to open these
meetings and these institutions to those
countries because nowadays with the
global economy with the global world
we're facing those country are playing a
major part so these are some of the
issues that are there on the table be
assured that France wants to go ahead
during his presidency and its
relationship with the United States
France wants to go ahead with a not
theological approach anymore maybe that
was France of a few years ago now we
have become more pragmatic maybe more
American in that sense and let's be
happy with that but this is certainly
the way we want to approach those
problem and we want to go ahead and we
intend to be as efficient and as helpful
and as constructive as possible as we go
ahead I stop there I've been too long
and I apologize but I'm quite ready if
we have a few more minutes to answer
your question if you wish so on any kind
of issue that you would like to ask yes
turkey you start there a very good
question and I must say a rather can
controversial one at the moment in in
Europe first of all let me remind you
exactly where we are at the moment in
fact we have all accepted all the
countries of the European Union we have
accepted to open negotiation with Turkey
on the question of a future membership
of of Turkey so that turkey could become
a full-fledged member of the European
Union on this question whether we keep
on with those negotiations or the
whether we stop them France has accepted
to go on with those negotiations the
truth is that those negotiation like the
ones we had in the past are there for a
long time they will take maybe six maybe
eight maybe ten years before we end
those negotiations you know the purpose
of those negotiation is to take out all
the European regulation that exists at
the moment and see how and when turkey
can take all this regulation on board so
that can take time because with some of
those regulation you are working on the
freedom of religion freedom of Education
the question of the political role play
by the Turkish army etc so those can be
very very sensitive issues but the
second point and this is where we have
some differences with some of our
partner is that France is of the opinion
for the time being at least but as long
as president Sarkozy is there he seems
to be a very much of that opinion and he
made that assessment very firmly we
think that turkey is not fit to become a
full member of the European Union for
many reasons one of them being that
turkey in fact is maybe more a country
belonging to the middle eastern New
Europe the part of the Turkish territory
inside Europe is a rather small one and
when you
come app you can very easily see that
turkey is mostly located in the Middle
East so we wonder whether we can say
that turkey could become a full member
of the European Union without creating a
precedence that some other countries
would like to ask for also and that
would bring about a major problem it is
also and it would be even more as we go
ahead a very important country in terms
of the size of its population in fact
when turkey if turkey should become a
member when turkey would come in the
European Union it would be the first
largest country in terms of population
even larger than than Germany and we
think that that we have to think also a
little bit about this with the risk of
creating maybe some instability inside
the European Union so there are other
reasons above for that one of the other
reasons being that we think it is time
maybe to reflect and to take some time
to reflect about what should be the
future of the European Union should we
go on enlarging this union every time a
new country ask for becoming a member
how far do we go is there any
geographical limit give me a
geographical border to the to Europe
where does Europe end and the other
countries start we have never really
managed to get a clear idea about that
one of the reasons we curbing that among
the present member state we are not in
agreement on that and we don't share
maybe the same the same ideas about that
so we think we France that it is better
to think a little bit more about that
before starting again and going ahead
with enlargement you know that at the
present moment we have one clear
commitment with regard to enlargement it
is towards the different countries of
the balcon area the former countries
that were part of the ex-yugoslavia this
is where we took a commitment so we
prefer to go on with that for the time
being allow for the negotiation with
turkey to go on and then at the end of
the disin ago
with turkey we will see where we stand
and we will look at the kind of
partnership we will have a turkey
because on this we are quite assured
that we want to have a very special and
narrow partnership with turkey but
something that could be just short of a
full membership so this is where we are
at the moment yes
I think so because since his visit to go
to newer many months ago he has he went
to other countries and has made
different statements and the latest one
was while he was in South Africa and he
made there a very important speech you
should go on the internet and try to
reach it because you would see that
there he has set up some of the new
principles he would like to see in the
relationship between Africa and and
France and those principles are very
important because they go for a clear a
new way of setting up the relationship
between France and Africa in order to
allow much more say to African countries
to see how we can go for a position
where nowadays with regard to African
affairs it would be for the Africans to
decide what they would do and ask if
they want to for France and systems
whether it be a political assistance
economic assistance development
assistance or if necessary if they wish
so military assistance but it is now
more and more for the Africans
themselves to decide what they want and
therefore we're in the process of going
through the all the different
relationship we have with each one of
those African country whether they be
French speaking or English speaking or
Portuguese speaking to see with them
what kind of relationship they would
have they would like to have what France
in in the future so we're starting this
process of changing rather profoundly
our relationship with with regard to
Africa we're only at the beginning of it
so you will see maybe still some some
transitional and provisional situation
being there but we're really going into
that direction and let's see what will
come out of this but the will the
willingness to change our relation is
there and very much there at the moment
yes sir
on the before coming to some of the
specific points you set up let me tell
you that the Europeans are very much
aware of the importance of the far east
of China in particular of older
countries and for many years what is
quite often the problem with the
Europeans as I was saying and mentioning
before is that to get a United view on
what they should do this is where it's
difficult you're trying to compare the
United States with Europe but you see
the difference is that the United States
is one single sovereign country that
decides on on its own about it what he
wants to do with regard to its foreign
policy in Europe we are 27 and at the
moment and contrary to what is sometimes
thought of about Europe is that foreign
policy was not there at the beginning
when we started the European Union
because we had failed right at the
beginning of the 50s to agree among
ourselves on what we wanted to do with
regard to defense and foreign policy in
fact the whole European construction
started only with the European matter
with the economic matters we created a
single economic market it took us 30 or
40 years to do that we talked about
agriculture about fisheries and things
like that but at the beginning we never
talked about foreign policy because it
was thought as being too federalist for
some and France among others we didn't
talk about defense etc so we've come
rather lately to start thinking of
having among ourselves a common foreign
policy and try to set up common
positions on issues and as soon as those
issues become controversial we have
difficulty in speaking with one voice
and coming back come to the point you
you stressed at the beginning of your
question under the question of the
present situation with regard to China
precisely we managed to agree only on a
very low profile and nothing really
precise for concrete came out of those
meetings and we stayed that so what did
France do France not the only one but at
I can speak for my country decided that
we should try to convince the different
parties to that difficult the situation
to start a dialogue in a political
dialogue and at the beginning we were
told that this was over optimistic and
unrealistic in fact it has happened and
the dialogue has started and we very
much hope that it will bring about some
good news in the end and some
constructive results and we have to wait
to see what will come out of this but
we're quite aware of the uneasiness that
that brought in China but we decided
that it was the best course to go to
push and promote the idea of a political
dialogue between the Chinese authority
and the Dalai Lama or his
representatives in fact this is in the
end what has started now and what we
hope will arrive at a good conclusion
yes yes
different
no no don't worry I've been asked that
many times because it's true that this
is a difficult question and a question
that is still there on the table whether
there should be a military option with
regard to Iran or not we tend to think
in France that we must not put the
question as such as i was telling
previously we had this course of having
on one side the sanctions and on the
other side the positive proposals and we
think we have to carry on with that
demotion that way of looking at things
and we think that as much as we have to
be very firm with the Iranians and even
increase sanctions as much as necessary
at the same time we have to be as open
as possible with those positive
proposals and once again we think that
one of the difficulties we're facing at
the moment it is difficult to get those
ideas through to the Iranians into the
Iranian public opinion and we think we
have to do some effort there because in
fact what is the real problem at the
moment is that we have the impression
that in Tehran at the moment the
difference that may exist among some of
the most radical inside a government and
some of the most moderate inside that
same government and that same regime in
Tehran those difference are there and
cannot be solved and therefore it's very
difficult at the moment to get any
opening or any new attitude on behalf of
the Iranian regime and we think that we
have to go on pushing as much as
possible in order that something happens
there because in the end of course it is
for the Iranians to the side so this is
where we are and this is the course we
intend to go on and we rather not speak
for the time being about military option
even if we understand that some summer
are talking about it would regard to
Iraq and I think everything is linked
there is as I was saying previously we
all know that today one of the
difficulties is if we want to find a
solution for each of those issues in the
Middle East this is going to become more
and more complicated because all those
issues are interlinked by the fact that
the actors are the same they're playing
in on each of those issues whether it be
in Lebanon in the Palestinian
territories in Iraq in with regard to
Syria etc and therefore at one point if
we want to solve one of these issues we
will have to look at the others and try
to find solutions there also so this is
why it is so complicated but we got to
Iraq we haven't changed our assessment
which is that the military solution to
us does not appear as the one who will
solve the issue in Iraq where we have
changes that we think that today the
international community cannot stay
aside from from that challenge that by
away or another the international
community the European Union France the
countries of the area Saudi Arabia Egypt
etc we all have to look and see if by
way or another we can help and bring a
contribution towards what should remain
the objective in Iraq which is some sort
of political dialogue and national
reconciliation between the different
communities their son eyes Shiites Kurds
this may take some time so the sooner we
managed to get all around the table and
work together the better this is the
French position at the moment so it's a
maybe a bit different from what it was a
few months ago when we prefer to stay
away from all this we are ready to bring
a contribution and to play a part but
this is a political contribution and
certainly not a military one
we will see but there I can't forecast
yes yes sir
no but but you're right and in fact this
brings us to one of the main features
that the trance tries to push as much as
possible with some of those issue you
were talking about that fool you were
talking about Burma it is the the
regional dimension in quite often in
other words for for crisis like da fool
we have been of the thinking very much
of the opinion that it was better for
the African Union to get the
responsibility for trying to find a
solution there rather than to go
directly to for international community
it is because quite often in which some
of those issue the African Union itself
has pleaded for the help of the United
Nations or the others that we have
decided to get involved and to try to
help but first we think it's better to
have the the countries of the region to
try to solve them because precisely if
they manage to get together and to find
their own way of solving the solution
it's usually the better way to do it and
that goes for for the food that can go
also for instance the difficulties
surrounding the Great Lakes area in
Africa that could be also the way to get
out of the situation that may arise or
that is arising in Zimbabwe at the
moment rather be for the Africans to try
to find by themselves a solution because
this is what we did in Europe in that
time that's what they can do and the
same thing goes with Burma it's maybe
better for the Chinese and the
neighboring countries surrounding Burma
to try to take the responsibility to
find a solution but the second point I
would like to stress is that it's for
each of those regions really to find
their own way of working together we can
give our expertise if they wish so but
the situation in Europe has been very
much different from the situation that
may arise in those country whether it be
the level of economic development
whether it be our history
europe is mainly the product of many
years of infighting between Germany and
France and that's because we had to go
through three difficult wars that at
Dell after those three difficult wars we
were we started to be a little bit wiser
and that we thought that maybe we'd
better try to work together rather than
fight each other all the time and this
is something very exceptional and that
belongs only to our history and on which
we have been able to build something
rather positive but it's not sure that
their same can be done with other
countries think for instance at the kind
of association that the Latin American
countries are trying to have they're
trying to go along a little bit as this
in the same way as the European Union
has done so but they're finding their
own tools their own rules their own way
of working together and it seems to me
that it's the right way to proceed
because they have their own history
their own tradition their own
relationship between themselves and
let's see what they will make out of
this that this may allow all of us to
share our experience to meet quite often
this is what we do but at the end it's
really for them to decide what they want
to do okay maybe one last question
because I think I have to run after
issue and besides I understand about the
region but what about the problems
veteran pockets all around the world and
it's trafficking such as selling a
bride's or child exploitation or selling
of organs where it's not just local well
they're quite often we rather go through
the United Nations because as this is a
really a world problem the it's for the
United Nations to deal with that and
inside the United Nations as often as
possible the 27 tried to speak with one
voice and on issues like that usually we
manage their fortunately to have to do
agree and therefore it's for the
presidency of the European Union to
speak in the name of all the 27 members
and this is what we usually do at the
level of the European at the level of
the United Nations okay
you